hello guys my name is the Cherno today
we're gonna be taking a look at Unreal
Engine 5's new amazing demo so yesterday
I woke up to like a lot of messages on
every platform telling me to check out
this amazing new demo that Unreal Engine
has released and I thought that it would
be fun to give you guys my thoughts on
this and I have actually seen it once
before so this isn't gonna be like a
completely new like reaction video or
anything like that it's more gonna be my
kind of thoughts on on this video but
the time that I did say this was quite
brief so this is going to be a little
bit more of me taking my time enjoying
the video and just letting you know what
my thoughts are I'm actually really
excited to look at this more closely now
for those of you who don't know who I am
I like to make game engines I worked as
a software engineer at EA on various
game engines first I worked on EA's
primary mobile game engine called Osiris
and then later frostbite in fact see I
have the frostbite pen this is all I
have now and then I quit all of that
because I wanted to work on my own game
engine called hazel as well as make
youtube videos for you guys so that is
what I am focusing on now ok so without
further ado let's dive in and take a
look at Unreal Engine 5 also I'll have a
link to this video of course in the
description below hello I'm Brian Karis
technical director of graphics here at
Epic Games
hi I'm Judith object / special project I
just want to say that straight away this
kind of engineer artist pairing just
completely reminds me of my life so back
at EA I did a bunch of like various
media things because of course i am i
have a youtube channel i can edit
youtube videos and all of that and i had
a friend and i still friends with
actually the technical artist that we
had on the team and the two of us would
always do things together we made
various like silly videos for like
internal EI use we even went to GDC
together in san francisco there's a good
time and this is just ah just so
nostalgic few years ago we got together
as a team and brainstormed where we
thought we could push forward state of
the art in real-time graphics
there are two key areas that stood out
the first dynamic global illumination
yeah um dynamic global illumination so
GI this is definitely one of the areas
that probably needs the most improvement
in in fact this is something like doing
Jimmy G iodine a mcclee is something
that the industry has been trying to do
for a very long time it's actually one
of the big reasons why we're separated
so to speak like fidelity wise with like
the film industry and offline graphics
because what global illumination is for
those of you who don't know is more or
less a simulation of how light bounces
in the real world so light doesn't just
kind of hit an object and then
completely disappear it bounces off an
object and then hits another object and
this kind of culmination of light
bounces is what gives every object you
see in the real world its color now in
offline graphics and like visual effects
for movies and all that they're able to
use ray traces which is basically a very
realistic way of rendering something but
it's very very slow and using a ray
tracer enables you to calculate the
light bounces perfectly however in
real-time graphics that's not really
possible to do at the same scale that's
why there's so much buzz about all this
kind of real-time ray tracing stuff
there's r-tx stuff it's amazing because
it lets us do certain ray tracing kind
of tasks in real time it can give us
perfect reflections or possibly more
importantly not perfect reflections
meaning kind of blurry reflections which
are very difficult to do otherwise it
can give us beautiful ambient occlusion
it can give us absolutely perfect
shadows all of these things we can now
kind of do in real time but it's not
really anywhere near at the same scale
in fact we rely on a lot of kind of
denoising algorithms to try and make the
scene look good because of the low
amount of samples or rays that we're
able to actually calculate so because of
all of this global illumination which
you know requires ray tracing
essentially it's very difficult to do
that and we have a lot of approximations
that try and kind of you know simulate
this light influence but ultimately it's
very difficult now doing all of this
offline is still something that the
industry does quite a lot meaning we can
take our time to calculate absolutely
perfect global illumination for a scene
and then bake it into some textures
which we can then just sample
run-time it's very very fast but it
means that everything has to be static
we can of course have multiple kind of
versions of these so we could have like
a morning scene and afternoon scene an
evening scene worth of like global
illumination but if the scene changes
dynamically that data is useless meaning
that like maybe if we have like a cave
and then a rock kind of moves off and
reveals all this kind of light entering
the cave now and that has to all bounce
around the cave and give it kind of that
ambient lighting we can't really do that
that has to be dynamic and that's what
they're talking about here beautiful
bounc lighting instantaneously I don't
have to be constrained to do a game
where the work has to be static and I'm
able to eat a lot faster and we yeah
that's that's important as well it's not
even about like making stuff dynamic
even for a static world if you're able
to kind of change the lighting as you're
working on that world and see it kind of
you know change instantly that also is
kind of quicker iteration times it makes
the development of the game a lot faster
because you don't have to wait hours for
your computer to figure out where on
earth the light bounces of going all
this new system lumen we're about to
show you what it is capable of but first
there was another area that we thought
we can push forward truly virtualized
geometry the artists won't have to be
concerned over poly counts draw calls or
memory could directly use film quality
assets and bring them straight into the
engine and that's a big deal parties I
just want to be able to import my ZBrush
model not photogrammetry scan my CAD
data without wasting any time optimizing
creating melodies or even lowering the
quality to make it hit framerate
and the end that's what it's all about
that's what I like about this as well by
the way everything I've heard so far
it's not just like an end result in
terms of visual fidelity these are
actually workflow improvements that's a
big deal because if artists can spend
less time doing like manual labor tasks
such as reducing the poly count of a
very high quality model they can just
put it in and let the engine take care
of it automatically that's honestly
amazing
they mentioned photogrammetry scans and
that's actually a really good example of
this if I go out with my camera and just
take this amazing like high quality
photogrammetry scan of like a rock in
the real world that's great it's gonna
look
amazing but I can't really use it in the
context of a real-time application or a
game because it's just too high quality
so I have to go in I have to kind of
remove everything doing this
automatically can sometimes lead to a
lot of visual artifacts so it's good to
just try and clean that up kind of by
yourself but the fact that you have a
rock with like millions of triangles now
and you have to spend time cleaning that
up it takes the fun out of everything
who cares about this rock like I'll just
build a rock from scratch you know sorry
environmentally realistic rock I can't
use you man you're too good so this is
this is good art it just works and we
hold this on technologists what that's
brilliant here is a nice feature of
Unreal Engine it's running live on a
Playstation 5 all right all right so I I
don't know the specs of a Playstation 5
um let me know off the top of my head I
know that they're supposed to be quite
powerful and I also do want to emphasize
the fact that it is new hardware which
means that I'm sure that they on one
hand they probably couldn't like do
amazing work with it that they will be
able to like 5 years from now because
you know at the introduction of any new
platform it takes a little bit of time
to get used to it but on the other hand
since it is a dedicated piece of
hardware if they were provided with very
good specifications and you know they
they probably collaborated with Sony on
this and they spent a lot of time on
this then potentially they could extract
a lot more performance from this than
from just a PC and the reason is that if
you're running on dedicated hardware
which I imagine has like ray-tracing cos
and all of this other like you know
dedicated hardware I guess then it's
actually easier to optimize for that
because if you know exactly what
hardware you're running on then you can
specifically optimize for that hardware
so I'm kind of torn like on one hand
PlayStation 5 ok that's cool this new
hardware but on the other hand since it
is like a specific piece of hardware
there's a lot of optimization potential
there as well
[Music]
this by the way I have so many things to
say at this rate I feel like this is
gonna be like an hour long so I might
just keep it a little bit more more you
know not as detailed Wow right off the
bat this kind of reminds me of the
photogrammetry style tests that embark
we're doing on Unreal Engine just I
guess maybe just cuz of the aesthetic
but looking at this seem like
immediately like the detail is
absolutely astounding it looks it looks
like it definitely could be an offline
render when the sound the sound is
really not any let's stop a moment and
take a look at some of the key features
of this demo much of what you see was
built with quick silmido scan assets but
instead of using the game versions we
use the cinematic versions which would
typically only be used in film they're
around a million triangles each thanks
to virtual texturing they all use 8k
textures as well
Nanuk can render an insane number of
angles very quickly there are over a
billion triangles of source geometry in
each frame billion with a be the nanite
crunches down losslessly to around 20
million at drawn triangles okay 20
million that's to quite alone what does
that many triangles look like I mean
maybe a ps5 can handle that but Wow okay
this isn't knowing is this is these are
these a triangles each a different color
yeah so what you're saying here is
essentially like a an ID of like a color
ID of each triangle here so each one of
these colors represents a different
triangle it's probably not enough colors
and I hate because I represent there's
actually it 20 million yeah there's not
there's not even enough colors there's
not even enough individual colors
available to us to actually visualize
all of these triangles so they're
probably having to reuse colors yeah
that's that's that's a lot of detail the
thing is with triangles in general like
they mentioned that you know is over a
billion triangles like that's all great
but the the reality is that you know if
you're rendering to like a full HD
display for example that's only about 2
million
and a 4k display would be well you know
four times that so it's like 8 million
pixels if you have that many pixels and
you have a billion triangles then you
know if what if if each triangle takes
up one pixel that's still too much data
so what they're having to do here I
imagine is some kind of dynamic like
level of detail algorithm or something
that's actually able to work out what
triangle of this kind of 3d model is
going to have the most influence on the
outcome of the scene and that's probably
the triangle that they end up picking
but again because it ends up being so
you know it's so small in this scene
like these triangles are tiny some of
them you can kind of see like you know
these triangles here obviously are quite
large you can see they're in the shape
of triangles here over here as well but
most of them since they're far away are
just one pixel large and if they've got
a good way to kind of call about lists
of triangles down and obviously have a
really good data structure that you know
is very cash friendly and all that so
they can actually iterate through those
triangles and get the right data for
each triangle as fast as possible then
they have to work out what triangle to
keep what triangle to discard and
essentially what data from that set of
vertices they actually want to keep and
then using like you know different
calculations that would be done in a
shader such as you know sampling from
textures lighting equations all of that
stuff so lots of work going on so small
the like noise nanite achieves detailed
down to the pixel which means triangles
are on the size of pizzas yeah exactly
this amount of geometric detail requires
shadows to be pixel accurate as well and
then I can do that too mm-hmm yeah I do
really wonder how they're doing shadows
specifically they mentioned that nanite
does that which is the virtualized
geometry thing but I guess that since
each since a lot of this is done kind of
in a per pixel basis they're just able
to you know you probably use those
billion triangles when trying to work
out what is occluded by you know what
occludes the light source and what
causes a shadow speaking of lighting all
of the lighting in this demo is
completely dynamic with the power of
lumen that even includes multi
pounds global illumination no light Maps
no baking here without UI all of that
people okay so this is without G I say
so this is just like a directional light
with like a shadow Kosta no bounce
lighting at all meaning that once the
light hits a surface it that's it
the light disappears and you can see
that it looks well looks terrible it's
completely dark you can't see anything
because the rest of what you're seeing
beautiful but imagine I'll show in a
minute with lumen enabled with dagger
that that is all of that light bouncing
around this entire environment all this
ambient light is actually calculated by
I guess in some way simulating or
tracing how the light bounces off the
surfaces that it does directly hit can
move the light and the bounce changes
instantly okay this is interesting so
they're talking about the bounce
changing instantly labeled we can move
the light but I can see here that if I
go frame by frame you can see that this
area as a changes doesn't immediately
change it kind of fades out it's
difficult to say whether this is a
deliberate visual effect
to make the light transition the same
smoother which it very well could be but
also what they might be doing is taking
a couple frames to actually recalculate
this new bounce lighting so the bounce
lighting can still be dynamically
calculated and baked into some kind of
light map and then obviously apply it
that way it's kind of cached and you can
keep reusing it without having to
calculate every frame which you know I
imagined they probably would be doing
some form of that and then you know
maybe if that lighting calculation takes
you know a couple hundred milliseconds
or a couple frames they can kind of keep
reusing the old ones while the new ones
are being generated and that way it
doesn't change instantly but you get a
transition but again they could be doing
in this oldest real-time I don't know
it's just that kind of fade seems a
little bit interesting but they they are
saying it's instantaneous so maybe it is
you move the light and the bounce
changes instantly
okay let's keep going we've made some
great additions to our audio system as
well
convolution reverb allows us to measure
reverberation characteristics of real
spaces like actual caves that we sampled
and reproduce them in virtual spaces so
this is really cool like first of all I
just want to point out that audio is a
huge deal like if you guys watch this
demo muted it will feel completely
different then if you watch it with
headphones and you know completely the
it adds so much immersion like audio is
incredibly important and I do not doubt
for a second that if they had not gone
with high quality audio and all this
fancy audio kind of technology that this
just would not feel anywhere near as
good they also mentioned sampling like a
real-world reverberation that's really
cool and that's really useful because
you know with physically based rendering
what people have done is they've kind of
gone ahead and sampled how light reacts
off of different surfaces in the real
world and how it like bounces off that
so that we can then use that in our
physically-based materials and that's
part of the reason why rendering looks
so good now so the fact that they're
kind of doing that same process
essentially for audio they're able to
actually measure really like reverb
characteristics in like real-world caves
and see how that reacts that's really
cool and that's definitely gonna bring a
whole new level of realism to just kind
of stuff sound field rendering allows us
to record and playback spatialized audio
so good all of this adds up to a more
immersive experience yeah I don't doubt
that animations are really on point as
well by the way like all of this stuff
like feels really good actually I really
like the kind of you can see that um you
can see that this kind of shadow here is
kind of it's a little bit red as well it
looks like it's kind of blending in with
the subsurface color which is again
really really nice and definitely has a
whole level of realism you can see the
light going through our fingertips and
all that subsurface scattering here is
kind of making all of this you know all
have her hands he looked a little bit
red and that that goes a long way to
making really good kind of realistic
looking skin so they've done a really
good job on that as well
this swarm of bats was created with a
Niagara effect system particles in
Niagara can now talk to one another and
understand their environment like never
before
if this sound is amazing festival but
then also the possible functionality to
run fluid simulations like you see in
the water below have to say that so far
I think the worst part of this demo is
the water I mean it doesn't look
terrible but I don't know people like
you know characters wading through water
that's that's been done better before
but you know I mean technically though
they could be running this on a
completely different level of
simulations so it's less static and you
know maybe that's why
[Applause]
the demo runs on our Kaos physics system
here we are using it to accurately
simulate the rigid bodies of the falling
rocks and the cloth of her scarf yeah I
imagine that each one of those rocks is
probably completely like a physics body
and reacts to the environment like it
should which is really cool
and of course the characters always have
thumbs kind of scarf or like a cape or
something on to get that cloth physics
in them I love the ambient particles
floating around the ones that aren't
really collide with anything but that
factor is a hole that goes a long way
for like visual fidelity as well now
that the environment is so complex we've
needed to greatly improve our animation
systems to adaptive we've added
predictive foot placement and motion
warping which dynamically modifies I K
and body position to look more natural
that's that's so true as well I'm glad
that he mentioned that you know because
they've come a long way in other areas
they now need to come a long way with
their animation because again like if
you you know if you have not-so-great
looking natural realistic animation but
it just looks realistic like everything
you're rendering looks realistic the
animation isn't it's gonna completely
just destroy your whole scene so this
animation looks very good and I think
that's also very the character to more
realistically interact with the
environment we've added the ability to
trigger seamless contextual animation
events like her hand on the door Thomas
mm-hmm-hmm yeah so the fact that she's
able to put that put her hand on the
door and that's obviously not like a
premade animation that's just a
contextual animation that the kind of
animation AI has probably figured out
based on the context of where she's
moving and how she's moving through the
scene I think that's you know that's
incredible and using that kind of
procedural AI animation really I think
is the future because you know for
example if your characters the wounded
maybe they've been like shot or
something and they like staggering and
they're just grabbing on to like nearby
objects because they can barely walk
that's gonna go a long way and I think
that that's that's really cool dynamic
Ti is amazing not just for speeding up
iteration but also for its impact on
gameplay
any light source can move while still
yeah say like the fact that I turned out
that this scene is completely dark
there's no light sources there's no
ambient light in the scene at all it's
enclosed the only light source entering
from the outside is quite far away but
she's got this kind of particle that's
that's emitting light
she is shining it and then you can kind
of see that all the areas around her
like they're very dark but you can still
make them out and that I imagine is
because of that dynamic kind of global
illumination line balancing well having
beautiful bounc lighting dynamic
illumination yeah and you can see that
specular reflection that he's talking
about and specular as well which you can
see on all the specular collection that
he's talking about all this Niagara
powered bugs reacting to the light yeah
and then the the fact of the particles
are acting to the light as well as
luminous not only reacts to moving
gathering all right but also changes in
geometry yeah well yeah I mentioned so
then of course it's dynamic yeah that's
all the dross sounds really good by the
way but also you can see that's what I
was talking about like you can bake
lighting for a scene and it can be
perfectly you can look great
but if you need to like remove part of
the same like this as a if it's not like
in one go they can see these rocks are
kind of gradually react like falling
away if we could rewind a little bit in
geometry yeah so you can see that the
rocks are kind of yeah they're falling
slowly away and revealing this stuff and
as that's happening like the scene is
getting brighter
I love the lighting on the actual rocks
falling as well looks really really good
and yeah there's that hole up there yeah
really cool and you can see completely
changed the lighting of the whole scene
right like it's now just completely
remember we mentioned highway all the
assets this statue is imported directly
from ZBrush and is more than 33 million
triangles no baking of normal maps no
authored LEDs yeah so that that's great
so no normal maps on on this at all and
no LR dates no level of detail kind of
models which is you know two things we
could talk about that but um essentially
the point of this I think is to
basically say that you can take this
amazing high quality model that you know
artists don't even have to worry about
that poly counts that triangles like I
mean they probably will you know
on one hand because I feel like if you
had this in Maya or in blender or
something like that and it was that many
triangles she's gonna make it very
difficult to work with but even if
Unreal Engine can handle it maybe the
other tools necessarily can but anyway
um you know having this having to not
worry about this having having the
ability to sculpt and model and do all
of that stuff with basically you know
seemingly infinite detail that's really
cool because it means that you don't
have to then go through and create all
these lots all these kind of level of
detail models which are basically just
you know lower poly count versions lower
quality versions of this original model
because you need them for different
rendering scenarios like if the camera
is very far away from this actual model
being able to get your like source asset
and just drop it in and have Unreal
Engine take care of the rest in real
time right in the runtime is amazing and
is making of normal Maps as well you
know normal maps are something that we
use to basically simulate more triangles
than there actually are so you can apply
a texture which has like per pixel
basically data which says we're like
certain you know certain triangles and
fake triangles we're then almost would
be if they were there and obviously if
we have 33 million triangles we don't
need normal Maps because we don't need
that kind of you know cheap way of
getting more detail because we have more
detail
and we can do more than a single statue
there are nearly 500 of that exact
statue at the same detail level placed
in this room for a total of over 16 yeah
that's amazing that is amazing just
having to sort through all this data
like you know I mean these are instanced
and everything but like I'm sure that is
damaged probably like over 100 gigabytes
if not hundreds of gigabytes because
there's so much you know texturing so
much to me triangles so much data so
just reading that data you know that's
why it's interesting to look at the ps5
architecture as well I'm sure that a lot
of this is obviously being streamed in
from disk every frame that disk that SSD
has to be blazing fast so how what
technology they're using but demo that's
gonna that kind of that like relation
between disk and then you know vram and
all that stuff has to be really tight
and I think that might be even specific
to this architecture there are hundreds
of billions of triangles yeah really
cool
[Applause]
[Music]
so with nanite you have limitless
geometry and with lumen you have fully
dynamic lighting and global illumination
yeah and then all gaming on a
Playstation five I should probably have
looked at the PlayStation 5 specs and
architectures below this video but I'm
assuming that's probably released by now
but yeah it looks absolutely amazing and
I also wonder what resolution this is
and I'm washing it in 4k so assume maybe
they're entering it from there but uh
yeah look at all that detail that's
really really amazing
lockout is everything's falling apart
around her because of course that makes
the technical demos seem better but
she's not she's really not having it
good to hate this doesn't need to be
constrained to small rooms it can
stretch all the way to the horizon hmm
I was waiting for this I mean I've
already seen this demo so I was coming
but I'm still waiting for it yeah well
just look at that
yeah not much stuff going on I feel like
we should always go through this frame
by frame that motion blur is pretty nice
we'll follow those rocks yeah this is
really cool also it's kind of hard to
tell because obviously this video is
compressed and put on YouTube but some
of the artifacts like I'm seeing
probably with video compression it's
difficult to say just like tell if
they're actually noise within the
renderer or if they're actually just
video compression I'm just assuming the
video compression though hmm
some of them are probably noise but yeah
this looks this looks phenomenal this
looks like a movie this looks like it's
been you know this looks like it's been
offline rendered for sure
and the thing that strikes me as well is
that you have to remember that this is
not just rendering this is not just a
scene that's been completely scripted
and it's not just being rendered a lot
of this is actually well it's it's
interactive right the fact that it's
interactive the fact that all of this
has to be simulated and you know kind of
computed in real time you know rendering
aside that's also amazing and obviously
with the kind of billions of triangles
that they're talking about with source
geometry there's more to that and
getting it on the screen you know
obviously it has to interact with the
environment around it and with the
player and that's a whole nother problem
of kind of dealing with models and
dealing with assets of that high kind of
high fidelity high quality stuff and
making them you know also be interactive
and all that stuff you know not just the
rendering that is impressive here for
sure
[Music]
depth of field is pretty nice as well
they've always had good depth of field
that I think that's really important
[Music]
well
that's probably right in real time as
well yeah that's amazing
2021
that's a while way all right sir yeah my
final thoughts on this are it is it's
incredible like it's really good there's
a lot there's a level of detail here
that we just probably like I don't think
we've ever seen before in any game
engine I think that I think they've
taken all of that 49 money and actually
like put it to very good use because
this stuff is for sure industry-leading
technology you know being able to deal
with that amount of source data in real
time and kind of work out what you need
what you don't how to put that on the
screen how to make it interactive that's
a huge problem and they're solving it
like well seemingly very well I can't
wait to actually dig through this and
see how it all works and they think I
think they did mention like a technical
breakdown would be coming so I'm really
really excited for that if you guys want
to see me talk about that as well drop a
comment below but in general yeah like
what do you guys think about all this
tech you know leave a comment below to
what you think the most impressive part
of this was I mean there are so many but
um I am interested to see what you liked
most of all if you did like this video
and you want to see more of this stuff
don't forget to hit the like button and
subscribe to this channel thank you guys
for watching I will see you next time
goodbye
[Music]
you